>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Maureen Corrigan: For those
of you who've just come in,
welcome to the Mystery
and Fiction Tent.
My name is Maureen Corrigan,
and I'm a regular reviewer
for the Washington Post,
and the book critic
for the NPR program Fresh Air.
Thank you.
[ applause ]
>> Maureen Corrigan: The
Washington Post has been a sponsor
of the National Book Festival
since it began 10 years ago.
It is my great pleasure to be
able to introduce to you one
of the great names of mystery
fiction, Martha Grimes.
I think -- yes.
[ applause ]
>> Maureen Corrigan: I think one
of the highest compliments I can
tell you about that's been paid
to Martha Grimes is that
even the British adore her.
[ laughter ]
And I think that the British in
general kind of take a dim view
to us Americans stepping
on their literary turf,
especially when that literary
turf is the mystery novel.
But Martha Grimes' novels manage
to capture the odd eccentricity
of England without committing
that greatest crime of --
in literature of being cute.
Her 20 Richard Jury
novels are set in England.
Imagine dampness, coolness, green
pastures, a landscape very different
from the landscape of
-- that you're in today.
They also all of them
take their titles
from the titles of
quaint English pubs.
Her newest novel is
called The Black Cat,
which of course has an
Edgar Allan Poe echo to it.
And without further ado, I will
introduce to you Martha Grimes.
[ applause ]
>> Martha Grimes: Well
thank you very much.
And I'm very glad to be here.
And I was reminded just a few
minutes ago by my PR person,
who is also my son, of the event in
Chicago, the Baucheron [phonetic] --
I mean I learned how to say it
before I went, but now it's all
over so I've forgotten
how to pronounce it.
And there was a similar setup where
you had an escort who would take you
to the room in which
you were giving a talk.
And we were standing at the
door while this other writer was
speaking, and I saw a boy,
this Dennis Lahane [phonetic],
who I personally love,
I love his books.
So I was standing there waiting to
go in, and his talk came to an end
and Dennis Lahane walked out
with his looked like two handlers
to me rather than escorts.
He walked out, and
when he walked out --
I mean there was thunderous
applause.
It was one of these long, narrow
rooms, something like this but not
as big, and huge applause.
So I walked in, and everybody
got up and walked out.
[ laughter ]
And I was watching.
>> But then I figured they're just
saying to themselves what the hell,
we're inside a tent, we
might as well hang around.
[ laughter ]
I was speaking a couple
of days ago to a reporter
about the National Book Festival.
He asked if I had ever been to
one before, one of these, the --
the, you know, sponsored
by the Library of Congress,
Laura Bush and people like that.
And I said yes, I think
I was in 2005, 2006.
And he said well how does it
compare with other festivals?
[ silence ]
>> Martha Grimes: I
had nothing to say.
I mean other festivals.
And he said, or large events?
[ laughter ]
And all I, you know,
I thought large event.
I said you know, I really
haven't been to any large events.
Of course I forgot the Baucheron
or however you pronounce it.
And I thought well, there's
the National Book Award,
I however have never graced,
it has never seen me there.
So festivals and large events.
And I thought to myself,
I wonder what sort
of image people have of writers now.
While I was talking to him I was
looking at the card, you know,
this -- it's really a
very nice logo, okay.
So I was sort of fooling
around with this card.
And I was thinking to
myself, oh, I guess this --
this shows you how observant I am.
I guess -- I guess
these are caricatures
of the writers who
are gonna be there.
[ laughter ]
And thinking that, of course I
started scanning it for my face.
Then we come to the
-- what is the tree?
I don't know who the tree is.
Then I started looking,
and wait a minute Martha.
He said these are famous
writers, well --
or famous characters
rather, famous characters.
This is really a -- a
marvelous sort of logo.
I hadn't even noticed that.
I thought that -- I
thought that these --
these people back here were sort of
kneeling over a kind of watermelon.
And then I realized hey, this is a
chair, and there's a girl sitting.
And oh for God's sake, these
are characters in books,
and this is just about
the imagination.
So I thought -- we were talking
about festivals and events,
the sort of life the writer leads.
>> Martha Grimes: I
remember one book signing,
a reader in the line said now
Mrs. Grimes I've written a book,
and I'd like to get some idea
as to how I shape my career.
And I said career?
He said yes, I want to
know what to do about it.
And I said well, you know, well --
well -- I mean, you know, here I am,
and I guess what I had is a career.
You -- you just -- you
said you've written a book.
Well you just keep on writing books.
[ laughter ]
And the sum and substance of
this is gonna be your career.
You see me -- you see me
opening this book here.
You think I'm gonna
read, but I'm not.
I'm trying to sell it.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: And
I never -- I --
I mean Mister Spencer
[phonetic] is a wonderful reader.
You know, I don't like following
people like that, and trying to --
I can't -- I'm a terrible reader.
And besides, people
think that if I'm reading
from a Jury book I'm gonna
do it with a British accent.
[ silence ]
>> Martha Grimes: But this
idea of the writer's life --
oh I've sort of killed
that one I think.
[ silence ]
>> Martha Grimes: I was gonna
say something back there
when we were talking about
the logo, about imagination.
In addition to the Richard Jury
books I also write, for you people
over there on the far left side
who are not paying attention.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: You know what
I've noticed about giving talks?
At just about every talk, I'm
looking at the people here
on the front row, I have found there
is always one person who hates me.
Now there could be many
more people who hate me,
but they're far more polite.
But the one who seems
to hate me the most sits
in the first row, front and center.
And just I think last
week I gave this --
this talk over in Friendship
Heights for Neiman Marcus' --
it wasn't in Neiman Marcus, I
would have been happy to have it
in Neiman Marcus, or -- or move
across the street to Bloomingdales,
that would have been delightful.
But there was a gentleman
in the first row
who clearly was not interested,
and who was there only
by I guess default.
But -- so I like to
yell you ought to smile.
I like to look over the first
row -- oh my -- oh it's my son.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: So imagination.
There is this series of books
besides the Richard Jury books.
They're narrated by this 12-year
old girl Emma Gramm [phonetic].
And these books -- these books
really are not mysteries.
There is a mystery in them,
they're not mysteries.
And I'm tired of people
sending me e-mails telling me
that they're really lousy mysteries.
[ laughter ]
But the -- and this is --
if you like Emma Gramm
books, this is the next one.
[ applause ]
Well I wasn't -- I wasn't
really looking for applause.
It says advance uncorrected
proof, not for sale.
But I figure you can either
be [inaudible] some questions,
we can have an auction.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: Anyway, the title
of this book is Fade Away Girl.
And for anyone who is -- I
was gonna say as old as I am,
but that cuts out about nine-tenths
of the audience right there.
Well actually even I'm
not quite that old,
but there was an illustrator, Coles
Phillips, who did a series of these,
and magazine covers, The New
Yorker, Saturday Evening Post.
I love this technique.
As you can see -- some of
you can see from this one,
the figure fades into
the background.
And he called this
technique a fade away.
So that's the next book,
now to sell my back list.
The last book was Black Cat, and
-- I heard an applau [phonetic].
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: That's terrific.
[ applause ]
>> Martha Grimes: I remember
when that comedian --
what is his name, he's very, very
funny -- had Tom Hanks as his guest,
and he introduced him as Tom Hank.
[ laughter ]
I always -- I -- I loved that.
So did Tom Hank, Tom liked it too.
The Black Cat is the I don't know,
the twenty-second or something
that like Richard Jury novel.
And I'm currently writing
another one,
at the same time I'm writing a
book with my son on addiction.
How about that?
You didn't see that coming, did you?
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: I remember a
book signing I had in Florida
where in the front -- and again,
it's the front row is the
place for this sort of thing.
In the front row a woman sat, this
was in a Barnes and Noble I think.
And she raised her hand
to ask a question, and --
and she said, Ms. Grimes, now I
have never read one of your books.
Now I always figure that right out
of the gate that's not what you say.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: You
don't have to say anything.
You don't have to say I've
read all of your books,
just don't say I've never read one.
You don't follow it up by
saying I'm with the prison --
the prison system, and I work
particularly in addiction,
drug and alcohol abuse -- alcohol
of course as we know isn't a drug --
drug and alcohol abuse,
and I just have a question.
I just -- now I notice all of
your books are named after pubs.
I said yes, they are.
And she said -- I couldn't
imagine where all this was going.
And she said well my question
is was there any alcohol abuse
in your family?
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: I said oh
yes, and you're looking at it.
[ laugher ]
[ applause ]
>> Martha Grimes: Can you imagine?
I mean there's this one question,
it's like well there is a lot more I
could say, there's also a lot less.
[ laughter ]
So -- but I would like you to
ask questions if you want to.
That's usually the way it
goes, no interest whatsoever.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: Yes.
[ silence ]
>> Martha Grimes: Scott
Spencer [inaudible] microphones
in the audience, I don't.
I'm sorry.
Oh, the microphones are up here.
>> I'm sorry.
I just wanted to know, you never
finished telling us what the man
in the front seat said to
you when you went to the --
you always said people
in the front seat.
>> Martha Grimes: Oh,
what about him?
Yeah, you knew him.
You know him.
[ laughter ]
>> It's probably my ex-husband.
>> I thought maybe
he made an odd remark
to you, that's why I was asking.
But I guess he didn't.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: I guess not.
>> I'd like to ask you -- I'm sorry,
I'm over here to the --
to the -- your right.
>> Martha Grimes: Oh, sorry.
[ laughter ]
>> You're a real pleasure.
My question to you is what's
your process for writing?
I mean do you just write
anyplace, anywhere?
Or do you have a special
place that you write?
Do you write in the
middle of the night?
Or what's your process?
>> Martha Grimes: Well my -- my
preferred place used to be a pub.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: But now
that avenue has been closed
to me forever I guess.
No, the process?
[ silence ]
>> Martha Grimes: Okay, number
one I don't wait for inspiration.
I don't wait until I want to write,
if that were the case you
all wouldn't be here today,
because you'd never see anything.
I write in longhand in notebooks,
and I try and do this for three
or four hours a day, in
the morning if possible.
Then I transcribe this
onto a computer.
And I have found -- you
know, the reason I write
in longhand doesn't have anything to
do with well, doesn't have anything
to do with what I'm gonna say.
What I've found was that when
the computer eats your work,
as it has been known to
do, and it was sorry --
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: -- I could go
back to notebooks and find it.
And that's really -- you know,
that's really quite a boon.
So I transcribe it on the computer,
and that's sort of the process,
if that's what you're talking about.
The things I don't do.
I don't have outlines,
I don't have summaries,
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know
[ laughter ]
-- I don't know what the plot is,
I don't know any of that stuff.
It's just sitting down writing.
And that's why I say to
people you seem to think --
a lot of people who
haven't tried writing seem
to think -- I'm not, no.
I'm sorry, I'm not.
The question time is not finished.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: Is
that Peter Straub?
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: That you really
don't have to have anything
in advance of just
writing, I mean just sitting
down with a pen and
a piece of paper.
And some people find it very
difficult to believe this,
but it's true, because that's
the way I started writing.
And I still do it that way.
And it doesn't get any
easier, I'd like to point out.
All right, I just had a 10 minute
card held up, which means I've been
on for 10 minutes, so that
means we've got another 25.
Yes, sir.
[ laughter ]
>> So with your alcohol
abuse that you mentioned
[ laughter ]
have you had a pint
in each of the pubs
for which you've named your books?
>> Martha Grimes: What
is -- what about the pub?
>> Have you had a pint
in each of the pubs
that you've named your books for?
>> Martha Grimes: Until lately.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: I have
been in every pub, every pub,
except for The Old Contemptibles,
and there were a couple of others
that were either logistically
impossible to get to.
But in -- I've been in
all of those pubs, yeah.
The Lamorn Wink [phonetic], and
of course all of these pubs are
in London, for which
unfortunately a couple of --
which have been changed and
modernized and so forth.
I mean The Five -- no, not
The Five Bells and Blade Bone.
Yeah, The Five Bells and Blade Bone,
which was a really great
grotty [phonetic] pub,
now is a -- what do they call it?
It's got a special
kind of designation.
Gastro pub for a fern
[phonetic] bar.
I haven't been into one of those
recently though, a gastro pub.
But they have snakes, they
have a boa constrictor,
a pet boa constrictor.
That's really taking it to
another level, isn't it?
Yeah.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: Yes, ma'am.
>> Hi. It's a real pleasure to
be here, to see you here today.
>> Martha Grimes: Thank you.
>> I -- I love all of your books.
And you haven't said anything
about your other series,
and I'm dying to know what's
going to happen after Dakota.
Do you have anything in mind?
Or are you -- are you
working on another?
>> Martha Grimes: Which
series are you speaking of?
Because there's more than one.
>> The -- the -- the --
the books that have --
that the last one was Dakota.
>> Martha Grimes: Oh,
oh yeah, oh yeah.
>> I'm dying to know what -- what
happened to that young woman,
so I'm -- I'm hoping
you're working on something.
>> Martha Grimes: Well I
certainly -- I certainly will be.
I have an idea for the third one.
But this young woman, Andi,
for anyone who is interested
in doing a complete literary
critique of all of my books,
I don't know if you've
noticed, a few have.
[ laughter ]
Indeed, it came to me as a surprise.
Andi is another -- there was
a book called The Deer Leap,
in which there was a character
named Kerry Fleet [phonetic].
Andi is another Kerry Fleet, she's
another Nell Ryan [phonetic],
the young woman in
The Grave Maurice.
And I have an idea that she
also has something to do
with that mysterious girl
in the Emma Gramm books.
But to answer your question,
absolutely I intend
to write another one.
I mean I keep turning books into
series, and it's got something to do
with not wanting to
let the characters go.
My publisher is dying for
the sequel to Send Bygraves.
Look -- look at that.
You see? You see?
Send Bygraves is a book of poems.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: Yes.
>> First of all, your
book on addiction --
and I appreciate that because I
have been addicted to your books
[ laughter ]
for absolutely decades now.
And I'm pleased that you're
going to do Fade Away,
because I've been waiting
for another one
for that series, so that's nice.
And my question though is
about the Richard Jury.
During all of the books
I've tried to assess
about how many years actually pass
in the lives of the characters.
>> Martha Grimes: Oh yeah, yeah.
>> And Carol Ann [phonetic]
seems to get no --
no older, and no less presumptuous.
So I wondered approximately how
many years are passing in the course
of the Richard Jury books.
>> Martha Grimes: Yeah, well I mean
you don't see me getting any older,
do you?
[ laughter ]
>> Well no, certainly not.
And I saw you about nine years
old, you don't look older.
>> Martha Grimes: Thank
you, thank you.
Yeah, this is a very good question.
Okay, let me point something out.
Many of these books, indeed
most of these books follow --
one follows very closely
after another.
So the first book was published
actually in -- in 1981.
Okay, in our time it is
now 2010, it is not 2010,
indeed the millennium hasn't
even come in -- in book time.
As far as the characters getting
any older is concerned now, I mean,
you know, really why should they?
Why should they?
But this, I would say that right
now we're kind of in the --
we're in the 90s, the
1990s in these books, yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Martha Grimes: You're welcome.
Good question.
Yes?
>> Hi. As much as I look forward
to your books and your stories,
I look forward to your
characters even more.
I can just see them sitting
around the pub, Melrose [phonetic]
and all the other characters.
My question is are they
based on real people
that you know, or your imagination?
>> Martha Grimes: Oh,
how I wish they were.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: Consciously,
none of the characters is
based on anyone I know.
>> Even Melrose's aunt?
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: Even Melrose?
>> Aunt.
>> Martha Grimes: Oh,
Agatha [phonetic].
>>
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Martha Grimes: Consciously, no.
Uh-uh. There's always
an Agatha, isn't there?
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: Okay, two minutes.
That gives us 13 [inaudible] to go.
Any other questions?
>> Yes.
>> Martha Grimes: Oh, sorry.
>> This side.
Oh, I'm sorry.
>> Hi, I just want to
say it's a pleasure.
I was on bed rest with my
second child for 30 weeks,
and I started with
the first Jury novel,
and went up until I think the
nineteenth one, and read those
in the 30 weeks I was on bed rest.
So thank you for getting
me through that.
[ laughter ]
>> Martha Grimes: You're welcome.
>> My question is when you finish
one do you know what's gonna happen
in the next -- kind of have an idea
of what's gonna be
going on in the next?
Or is it just you finish one
and then you don't have any
idea of what's coming up?
>> Martha Grimes: I don't
even know what's going
on in the one I'm writing.
[ laughter ]
So any future projection is
-- that's not completely true.
Occasionally my mind will dart
out to something or other.
That's about as vague
as -- as you can get.
I'll -- I'll tell you one thing.
The -- although I said, you know,
I don't wait for inspiration before
I write, a lot of inspiration comes
from the actual names of pubs, like
the Richard Jury book I'm trying
to work on at the moment.
It's purely on the
basis of pub name.
And for some reason there is --
the names have some
kind of emotional weight
that I don't really understand.
So some of these names I regard
as irresistible, you know,
I am the only running
footman [phonetic].
I mean, you know, how could
you think of better titles?
Although people can't
remember the titles,
which is definitely a negative.
But why am I -- why am I here
wondering what to say next?
Did I answer your question?
>> Yes ma'am.
>> Martha Grimes: Thank you.
>> Hello.
>> Martha Grimes: Oh
we're into overtime.
The Redskins might like
it, I don't know that --
>> All right.
>> Martha Grimes: Right.
>> You do so well with
the verbiage coming
out of the cockney
or whatever, English.
How often -- how long do you
spend in England each year?
Or did you just live there some
time, and now know how to speak it?
>> Martha Grimes: I don't
really know how to speak it.
I sort of absorb the
speech patterns I guess.
The longest I was in England
I guess was about what,
four months, five months in England.
And for the most part
it's visiting every year,
for a relatively short
period of time.
For some reason I just sort of
-- I'm really just a sponge.
I mean I just sort of --
I'm able to absorb this
when I can't absorb anything else,
except what I already [inaudible].
[ silence ]
>> Martha Grimes: Anything else?
All right, good for you.
:
>> Martha Grimes: Thank you.
[ applause ]
>> Martha Grimes: Thank
you very much.
I like -- I usually like to say that
if it weren't for you all sitting
out there, I would not
be standing up here.
So I think the thanks goes
in the other direction.
Thank you.
[ applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.